thank you
what a mind-blowing finish to an
incredible game tonight with Charlie
Sanders winning the game in literally
the last second uh unbelievable truly
spectacular Charlie Sanders how does it
feel hey y'all want to say something to
everybody watches yo you can do anything
anything's possible The World is Yours
Charlie did you think that that game was
going to end that way tonight yo there
are no limits all right you can swim
across here learning you can jump real
high and touch the moon fantastic
Charlie Sanders fresh off of his uh
Victory uh it just feel like he's ready
to touch the move [__] fly anybody
can fly if you believe in yourself the
way I believe in myself tonight you will
fly and what's next for Charlie Sanders
and the orange you can actually fly no
no not well not literally yes literally
kids young kids I want you to go up on
your roofs right now wait what fly into
the night sky okay people will see you
flying and you can do anything you can
do anything okay well we we just want to
remind the kids that of course you
cannot actually fly kids oh y'all screw
that negativity man hey boys and girls
ages eight through twelve yo don't let
nobody ever tell you what you can and
cannot do all them pre-teen children out
there listen to my voice you are
Immortal okay well obviously we
understand that Charlie is super excited
right now and that no one is actually
Immortal no at all kids you could turn
yourself into a car and have a friend
drive you onto the freeway okay no well
that's just a metaphor kids we don't
have the power of childish innocence get
a friend on your back and make a v alarm
for the next ramp to the freeway y'all
okay don't do it freeway speaking figure
it out once you get there ain't nothing
bigger about this you will turn into a
robot first and foremost I just want to
say the 12 families who lost children
sorry
my statements were irresponsible
have subsequently looked up the terms
literally and metaphorically and found
that whereas I was not incorrect they
did not mean what I thought they had
meant
hey it's a dinkelage yeah the carpetron
check out Leos
I wonder what he's dreaming about he is
probably dreaming about what we is going
to do to the team from the West
I wonder
[Music]
Tavarius Miss T King for short I'm a bad
mama jama and an awful sport Smoochy
Wallace you could call me Ty Royal
rapping up Russians like aluminum foil
the queen Goldberg
harbatron Duke Marion I love the ball so
much I Wanna Marry it
oh yeah
that we are the best
we are the best
I'm an Ibrahim moist and my Rhymes are
clean like my name was Dr Seuss Papa cut
the third they call me the probe okay
that's my name power candle sounds the
same with Jack Mary javares from Lamar
black and wax and play Saxon Demarcus
plays guitar
[Music]
okay don't you know
that we are the best indeed we are the
best
it must have been all a dream
or was it
hey hey come on
[Music]
[Applause]
Aurora
[Music]
here guys
knock it off you can't do that guys guys
guys listen no
Rafi just got out of treatment remember
we don't want to trigger him with teni
slapas
you're going on here
hey good game
good game man
good game
okay
there's an elephant in the room
you know I want to talk about
[Music]
I had a problem
and my lowest point
I would sneak into a horse's table
when you find yourself at 1am in the
morning with your hand in the air
in front of your face that's when you
know it's bad
I mean I'm okay now
I'm all better guys honestly just treat
me like a normal okay okay
okay here
you can pick up your glass
laughs
[Music]
hey what I told you huh it's just normal
guys come on I think I'm fine I'm all
better now you guys can do the normal
stuff be yourself Bend things over pick
things up you know do your stretches
touch your toes you're stupid
excuse por favor
hola amigos
my name is Reuben
I just came over from the the Braves
farm team and from the Dominican
Republic
I'm really excited to be working in
playing with you all go rhinos
all right we're gonna need a bigger boat
what the uh
I guess so
spending enough a lot of time down there
you know hey I have a lot of stuff yeah
a lot I see that you
love you oh my God
you okay there buddy not looking too
good
I am feeling a bit flushed you know I
got a good feeling about you
maybe we could be good friends maybe
even the best of friends
maybe another time
another place
I know you
know not now
well either way we're teammates and so
anything I can do for you
ask away got it okay go rhinos oh
no Ruby
[Applause]
[Music]
I know
hard to receive
D okay
are you okay
[Music]
I'm okay okay
guys you know maybe after a game Victory
we can all go dancing right
[Music]
[Laughter]
all right
[Music]